esta soy yo cuando chiquita
crecí entre el campo y la ciudad vivía
en el campo y el colegio en la ciudad
para muchos de ustedes seguramente estos
dos espacios son opuestos pero para mí
nunca lo fueron de hecho siempre se me
sentí como un puente entre estos dos
espacios
y tal vez eso fue lo que hizo que
estudiara antropología y que trabajó con
comunidades locales en temas de
territorio y medioambiente
y si hay algo valioso que aprendido de
las comunidades es el vínculo con el
territorio y aprendido que el ser humano
es una extensión del territorio y el
territorio es una extensión del cuerpo
humano
y es que hay muchas maneras de ser ser
y aquellas comunidades que tienen ese
vínculo estrecho con el territorio le
dan valor a aquellos elementos que son
vitales para la vida como el agua y el
suelo fértil como nos contaba el aura
ahora más temprana
a tal punto que muchas de estas
comunidades en su territorio como su
propia madre como en el caso de este
campesino en la región del tolima que me
decía que defendería el río y en el que
se bañó desde niño como su propia madre
y a mí me ha parecido fascinante ver
como ese vínculo con el territorio
detona movimientos sociales de base en
defensa del territorio
y estos movimientos de base tienen una
cosa maravillosa y es que surgen líderes
emergentes que tal vez no han estudiado
maestrías y doctorados pero que ese
vínculo con el territorio y su
compromiso por defender lo hace que se
expresen todas esas cualidades de
colectivamente defender su territorio de
una con un liderazgo que es compartido y
horizontal
muchos de nosotros no lo sabemos pero a
lo largo de la historia de nuestro país
estos movimientos sociales han influido
en decisiones que han tomado la corte
constitucional
gracias a la incidencia de grupos
humanos que han querido participar en
las decisiones que afectarán su futuro
en este país se han formulado políticas
y programas de gobierno que responden a
esos intereses de la sociedad civil de
hecho por esa razón colombia a nivel
internacional es reconocido como un país
de vanguardia en términos de
reconocimiento de derechos
algo que a mí me parece fascinante de
estos movimientos de base es que se
organizan de una manera muy distinta a
la manera en que se organizan y se
organizan las organizaciones
convencionalmente porque no son ni
centralizadas y descentralizadas sino
distributivas y eso hace que surja una
inteligencia colectiva democrática que
es solidaria autodidacta autónoma
emergente libre y colaborativa para mí
todas estas cualidades son muy femeninas
y son aquellas cualidades que como seres
humanos debemos incorporar a nuestras
vidas para poder afrontar los retos que
tenemos hoy en día
estos movimientos además funcionan a
partir de principios de cooperación
reciprocidad y respeto mutuo a
diferencia de nuestro sistema
convencional que se organiza a partir de
elementos como la competencia y el
consumo y esto todavía sigue muy vivo en
las comunidades tradicionales por
ejemplo cuando tienen que hacer un
trabajo colectivo grande convocan a una
minga como este señor en la foto que
invito a todos sus vecinos a que le
ayudará a como a construir la gran casa
o la gran maloka en la que viven
y entonces estos movimientos sociales
e imitan o más bien incorporan elementos
que utilizan la naturaleza en su
estrategia que él ha hecho exitosa por
millones de años y es a partir de la
solidaridad y la colaboración que se
organizan
y entonces lo que a mí me parece
fascinante es que entonces los seres
humanos cuando estamos expresando ese
vínculo con el territorio y nos
organizamos colectivamente para
responder a ese vínculo estamos actuando
como parte del sistema vivo
y adoptamos una de las propiedades más
bellas de la naturaleza una que se ha
mencionado varias veces hoy en el
escenario que es la resiliencia y es la
capacidad de un sistema de evolucionar
para sobrevivir los cambios a los que se
enfrenta al cambiarse a sí mismo
y así surgen alternativas reales para
las comunidades basadas en las riquezas
del territorio y en los atributos de las
personas que lo habitan y estas
alternativas son las que realmente nos
demuestran que es posible basar nuestro
sustento en alternativas que traigan
bienestar tanto para las comunidades
como para la para el medio ambiente como
el caso de los campesinos de cajamarca
que escogieron darle dignidad a su
identidad campesina mantener la vocación
agrícola de su territorio
y fortalecer su identidad al
comercializar la arracacha a cajamarca
es el productor número uno de arracacha
en el mundo y además esta región es
conocida como la despensa agrícola de
colombia y estos campesinos han tomado
la decisión con convicción absoluta de
que quieren mantener esa identidad y esa
vocación agrícola y entonces han hecho
contactos muy importantes con
restaurantes como crepes waffles en la
ciudad para resignificar este
ingrediente que es utilizado ampliamente
en las cocinas rurales pero muy poco en
los restaurantes en la ciudad y esto se
ha convertido en una alternativa real
para los campesinos y su identidad
esto es un ejemplo de cómo las
comunidades pueden escoger su buen vivir
pueden definir desde sí mismos lo que
para ellos es bienestar y qué bienestar
le quieren dejar a las generaciones que
vienen es una capacidad de auto de
determinar colectivamente qué es lo que
quieren para su futuro desde su propia
manera de ser ser humano
y yo me di cuenta que esto tenía un
valor gigantesco y un poder infinito y
trabajando con una de estas comunidades
sentí la necesidad de sacar estas
historias de colombia y darles
visibilidad internacional entonces con
uno de los casos escribimos una carta a
comunidades que estuvieran haciendo
procesos similares en otros países y fue
cuando me di cuenta que la solidaridad
tiene el poder de convertir una voz en
un movimiento
así es realmente para puesto en práctica
esa esa identidad que sentido desde niña
de ser puente entre mundos y ha tenido
la oportunidad de visitar muchas
comunidades alrededor del mundo llevando
las historias de él desde lo local a
otros lugares que aunque son diferentes
comparten cualidades similares y
aprenden de las estrategias que otras
comunidades han aplicado
y así me he dado cuenta que en a pesar
de que estos estos procesos tienen
expresiones diferentes en cada uno de
los lugares en donde se vive porque está
informado por el contexto propio la
cultura y la identidad local hay
elementos comunes que si se ponen en
relación fortalece y potencializar los
procesos locales y le da vida a nuevas
oportunidades al igual que este
entramado que no determina por dónde va
a crecer la planta si de la si le da la
oportunidad de trepar yo he tratado de
hacer lo mismo con esas comunidades
brindando y facilitando procesos para
que cuando se encuentren y comparten sus
estrategias se empoderen y potencialicen
sus procesos
y entonces yo me he preguntado qué es lo
que está pasando qué es lo que nos están
proponiendo estas comunidades y me ha
dado cuenta que lo que nos están
proponiendo es un cambio de paradigma
que nos aleje de un modelo en el que el
ser humano es la cúspide de una pirámide
en la que podemos utilizar la naturaleza
a nuestro antojo basado en principios
jerárquicos y de competencia y nos
invita a pensar nos como parte de un
sistema a partir de la participación y
la colaboración
y estas comunidades entonces nos invitan
a preguntarnos y a repensar la manera en
cómo participamos en el sistema vivo que
nos sostiene como ese niño que está
eligiendo participar impactando su
contexto más cercano que es el bosque de
su comunidad
y creo que es una pregunta muy valiosa
y es una oportunidad que tenemos todos
nosotros repensar la manera en que
participamos en el sistema vivo que nos
sostiene
porque cuando lo hacemos entendemos que
de la participación de cada uno de
nosotros depende de la resiliencia del
todo
y porque él es través de esta historia
hoy a ustedes y no quiero que se queden
como una historia de experiencias
locales en lugares remotos de este país
y es porque estoy absolutamente
convencida de que la única manera de que
nos realizamos con los seres humanos es
cuando entendemos que hacemos parte de
algo más allá de nosotros mismos
como esta niñita que participa en una
comparsa y alegremente de una manera
única y particular entrega su sonrisa a
un colectivo entonces creo y estoy
absolutamente convencida de que a pesar
de que podemos alcanzar muchos elementos
de que hacen parte de la definición de
riqueza de éxito con la que nos
enseñaron a vivir estoy absolutamente
segura que en aislamiento nunca vamos a
alcanzar una sensación de plenitud y de
realización como la que alcanzamos
cuando realmente entendemos cuáles son
nuestros regalos únicos como individuo y
cómo nos ponemos al servicio de ese de
ese todo más allá de nosotros mismos
porque ahí entendemos que estamos
contribuyendo y que estamos participando
y que estamos entregando un regalo único
a este sistema del que hacemos parte
y es que las comunidades tradicionales
lo han sabido desde hace muchas
generaciones y lo siguen poniendo en
práctica por eso todo el andamiaje
cultural de las comunidades
tradicionales está diseñado para
acompañar al individuo en su proceso de
transformación a lo largo de su vida
brindándole los elementos para que se
entienda a sí mismo como parte de un
colectivo
y ellos se entienden muy bien que el
todo es más que la suma de las partes
entonces yo los invito a que nos
preguntemos cuál es su todo
de qué colectivo hacen parte
como contribuyen a que ese colectivo sea
la mejor versión versión de lo que es
tengo una hija de un año y medio y ahora
sí quién hago esta pregunta todos los
días que pasa si pensamos nuestro todo
más allá del mundo con el que
interactuamos en nuestra vida diaria
qué pasa si entendemos que ese todo es
el planeta que nos regala la oportunidad
de vivir
entonces por eso los invito a que
recuperemos el poder de lo colectivo
porque no podemos poner en duda que un
pequeño grupo de ciudadanos conscientes
y poco comprometidos
tiene la capacidad de cambiar el mundo
de hecho es lo único que lo ha logrado
gracias
[Aplausos]